على المستوى الشخصي في هذه المرحلة ،
أود أن
أقول إنني سئمت قليلاً من الإنترنت ،
والشركة التالية التي أفعل فيها
أحد الأشياء التي أعتقد أنها ستكون
مهمة هي أن لها بعض
التأثير المفيد على المدى الطويل الذي
أهتم به  القيام بشيء في
مجال مختلف بالعودة إلى
سبب خروجي في الأصل إلى
وادي السيليكون والذي كان يدرس فيزياء الطاقة ،
بدأت العقارات
في الانخفاض أخيرًا في الأسعار ،
أعتقد بحكم التعريف تقريبًا أن امتلاك
أسلوب حياة أمريكي تقليدي هو
تناقض للسيليكون
لا يمكن أن يتزامن الوادي أو الاثنين على الأقل ، فهو
لا يجذب أولئك الذين يبحثون عن
المال السهل لدرجة أنه كان
عليك قضاء قدر هائل من
وقتك في العمل ،
لذلك لا يوجد شيء مثل
الثماني ساعات  يوم
في وادي السيليكون في أي مجال
منذ ما يقرب من عامين ، بدأت
x.com ، نحن حوالي خمسة أشخاص فقط في
المجموع ، الشركة تضم الآن أكثر من 600 شخص ،
وأود أن أقول إنها كانت ناجحة إلى حد ما
بالنظر إلى أن موقع
x.com يسمى الآن  باي بال هو
الموقع المالي الأول في العالم
[موسيقى]
الذي تريد الحصول عليه من فتاة باريس ،
لقد وصل إلى النقطة التي لم
أرغب فيها حقًا في أن أكون
أه لم أكن مناسبًا تمامًا لإدارة
شركة بهذا الحجم ولم أكن على
وجه الخصوص  مهتمًا بالفوز بشركة
تزيد عن 600 شخص ،
لذلك قررت أن
أبقى مديرًا للشركة ولكن
أبحث عن شيء آخر أفعله
على المستوى الشخصي في هذه المرحلة ،
أود أن
أقول إنني تعبت قليلاً من الإنترنت في
الشركة التالية  قم بأحد الأشياء
التي أعتقد أنها ستكون مهمة هو أن
لها بعض
التأثير المفيد على المدى الطويل ، فأنا
مهتم بعمل شيء في
مجال مختلف بالعودة إلى
سبب خروجي في الأصل إلى
وادي السيليكون والذي كان يدرس فيزياء الطاقة
أنا سعيد لأن إيلون لم يعد
جزءًا لا يتجزأ من فقاعة السيليكون
، لقد كان ركوبًا سريعًا
من حيث مشاهدة
اه إيلون يمر بتجارب
ومحن العمل والتكلفة
التي تعرف أنها تتكبدها في علاقة.
كما هو الحال
في مستشفى إلينوي لمدة شهرين ،
أصبت بالملاريا ، صعدت عندما ذهبت
لزيارة جنوب إفريقيا ، جئت في غضون 36
ساعة من الموت
، كان أمرًا لا يصدق ، لم أكن خائفًا بعد ذلك
لأنني
لم أستطع التفكير في حقيقة أنك
قد تموت بسبب  مررت بهذه
التجربة يعطيني حقًا
إحساسًا بالجوانب الأخرى للحياة وتقدير
الأصدقاء والعائلة
وقضاء الوقت مع الأشخاص الذين
تحبهم
بشدة ، كانت فكرة
تعرضك لهذه البعوضة الصغيرة
صدمة حقًا
وكرائد أعمال في وادي السيليكون  أنت
لا
تفعل ذلك كثيرًا ،
انظر إلى كل عمليات الهبوط التي قمت بها ،
لقد اشتريت للتو طائرة كنت أرغب دائمًا
في الطيران وتعلم أن أكون طيارًا
ويجب أن أحصل على رخصة طيار في
وقت قريب
جدًا.  بعض
الأصول الرائعة
التي تعرفها مثل طائرة ماكلارين ، أنت
تعرف أمرين لكنني كنت
سأندم كثيرًا إذا توفيت في
المستشفى لأنك تعلم كثيرًا أنك أهملت
الكثير من
الأشياء على الصعيد الشخصي  جانب للعمل